oui les grands legrand l'os une le grand
écrivain chinois disait après avoir
écrit coupez coupez coupez coupez way
jusqu'au bout a comparé alors en chine à
propos de cosmopolitisme vous vous êtes
le vôtre est planétaire parce que on le
voit bien dans ce livre la vie de
famille chinoise une famille américaine
et une famille indienne à une famille
belge est venu buzz alors faut pas
oublier ma mère la famille chinoise
c'est votre père c'est mon père la
famille chinoise nous sommes maintenant
sens dans notre génération seulement ça
c'est très petit alors la famille belge
c'est la famille de votre mais la
famille de ma mère ils sont aussi assez
nombreux la famille américaine
la famille américaine c'est mes deux
soeurs avec leurs enfants
ma fille une de mes deux filles deux
filles adoptives vous savez j'ai une et
à singapour et donc commencer une
famille dans le sud est asiatique ça
c'est la 5ème famille est alors l'autre
fille a épousé un américain est à new
york
et puis et c'est là le sujet de votre
livre la famille indienne
oui j'ai posé un indien c'est mon
troisième mari mon premier thé chinois
mon deuxième anglais mon troisième
indien je crois que ça me fait très
cosmopolite vous êtes là elle se
souvient du je crois que vous êtes
certainement une championne du monde du
cosmopolitisme hausse à oui bon alors
pourquoi aviez-vous et lausanne en
présence de cernobbio dia les habitués
de la même ville
je crois que je me suis dimitrijevic je
suis sûr de mon avis que lausanne c'est
un peu un centre mondial
vous savez pourquoi parce que tout
d'abord tout marche ce qui est épatant
pour un écrivain et deuxièmement pour
moi il y a quatre avions par semaine
pour la chine et je reçois mon courrier
en trois jours alors voilà pour moi
c'est très important alors troisièmement
le téléphone suisse mais c'est
merveilleux
partout chocolat aussi non ah oui au
très très souvent hélas d'aussi alors
tout est à proximité tout est prêt pour
moi à lausanne je crois que vous aussi
vous trouvez que nos ancêtres est
confortable oui je pense mais enfin je
ne vois pas beaucoup la bid
ils y vont en 1956 vous tombez amoureux
d'un indien qui est un ingénieur indien
et et vous entrez dans une famille
indienne qui très catholique
oui qui est très catholique oui oui
alors que vous vous êtes une catholique
qui a rénégat renégate et l'aps oui
alors que le le père de votre votre
fiancée entre guillemets quand il n'est
pas mon chien oui mais enfin
non on n'a jamais passé par le stage de
fiançailles et je doute même qu'on soit
peu marié l'en face à ferrer à ça on en
parlera donc le et vous entrez dans
cette famille chrétienne indienne et
vous êtes accueillis avec beaucoup de
tolérance
oui elle cessa précisément qui est si
merveilleux mais vous voyez le
catholicisme aux indes
comme je le dis dans le livre date
depuis saint thomas c'est le plus vieux
catholicisme du moins vous en france
vous êtes seulement catholique de peak
oil au huitième seulement depuis le
viiie siècle non alors ils ont 8 oui
siècle d'avant sur vous c'est saint
thomas qui est allé là et c'est pour ça
que comme vasco da gama et les portugais
sont arrivés et bien il y avait trente
mille nazaréen on les appelait qui sont
venus les accueillir à cauchy à port
indien et vincent quand vous entrez dans
sa vie il a déjà trois enfants
oui il était marié et avait trois ans il
ya une fille qui s'appelle patriciens
oui un autre des deux fiches l épée
terre alors est ce lui qui valide qui
est le sujet de ce livre ccpt ritter c
est l office a un fils un garçon
charmant merveilleux qui est venu me
voir très souvent on est devenus
extrêmement amis alors qu'il est le met
pas au début mais non il ne m'avait pas
vu alors il avait des idées n'est ce pas
évidemment il avait tout à fait raison
c'est moi qui avait cassé la famille
c'est moi qui avait brisé
ceci est d'ailleurs toujours incommodé
évidemment mais il avait donc cette idée
qu'il allait mal
il est venu pour me yves et n'aura pas à
y est on est s'est très bien entendus et
même on s'aime beaucoup est alors celui
qui est devenu malade handicapé bon oui
c'était un ingénieur il parcourait le
monde vous il va faire des forages en
iran etc et en libye on ira et vers
l'âge de quel âge il tombe malade
trente trois 33 ans et là il a économisé
méningite tuberculeuse mal soignée pas
diagnostiquée à temps il est entré dans
le coma
et puis alors après il est devenu tout à
fait incapable et alors vincent et moi
on a dû faire face à cela et c'était
pour moi une expérience que je n'avais
pas eu malgré le fait que j'ai été
médecin pendant 14 15 ans mais c'est
différent de s'occuper des autres et de
la voir soi-même et tout d'un coup je me
suis dit mais en fait il y a beaucoup de
gens dans le monde qui ont des handicaps
et qui ont des enfants retardés qui ont
des malades qui doivent s'en occuper
et alors voilà ça nous est arrivé à nos
alors vincent et moi on s'est occupé de
mon c'est vincent c'est mon mari qui l'a
sorti du coma en lui parlant de 9 heures
du matin à six heures du soir tout le
temps alors je ne fasse votre mari est
derrière vous et voilà parce que je ne
parle pas français je crois non non pas
du tout donc voilà vincent est là et
c'est vrai qu'il est d'un dévouement
prodigieux pour son fils mais au point
que cela crée des problèmes entre vous
deux
qu'est ce que certains moments il
préfère s'occuper de son fils plutôt au
club de vous ce n'est pas préférence
c'est une question de goût est le devoir
et la responsabilité
et comme il me l'a dit toujours et c'est
vrai il me dit maintenant tu es forte
c'est à dire que j'ai l'air très fort
ils se rendent pas compte parfois les
hommes ne se rendent pas compte parfois
qu'une femme peut avoir l'air très forte
très indépendant mais qu' on a toujours
besoin d'un peu d'émotion d'amour de
quelqu'un là c'est très féminin je
m'excuse peut-être que les hommes sont
plus indépendants mais je crois qu'une
femme en a besoin et que cas parfois ça
fait mal
enfin il fallait il fallait pour lui et
pour moi se dire voilà il faut faire ce
qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il fallait
faire c'est s'occuper de peter et donc
vincent à part pour s'occuper de peter
mls oui il est très souvent pendant ces
dix ans presque six mois de l'année il
était pas là ce qui fait que d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens ont cru que nous étions
divorce et nous ne sommes pas du niveau
que vous cherchez un quatrième mari non
je mets vraiment vraiment mais j'y songe
maintenant peut-être que j'aurais dû
être portées je n'ai pas vous être un
prix nobel d'afrique
revenons à ce livre qui est grave est ce
que vous montrez aussi celle influence
de ce malade qui est complètement un peu
tant qu'anti là qu'il ya 40 ans il faut
vraiment le s'occuper de lui tous les
jours et c'est vrai qu'il va faire des
progrès et redevenir ne peut être pas
lui même en fait par devenir quelqu'un
qui peut qui va pouvoir vivre tout seul
presque mais mes os qui vous montrez
bien c'est l'influencé qu'il a sur vous
mais oui mais ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que voici ce qui est arrivé à
cause de sa maladie il n'a plus la
censure mental que nous avons toujours
censuré deux mêmes vous l'aimez prier
vidéo on se sent sur soi même n'est ce
pas tout le temps il faut dire ça faut
pas dire ça faut être gentil quand on
n'a pas envie lui et n'a pas ça c'est
fini
donc il a nommé face à des vérités sur
nous mêmes que nous ne voulons pas et
c'est là que cette extraordinaire et que
quelques fois je me dis qu'il est plus
normal que beaucoup de gens qu'on
appelle normal parce qu'il n'a pas su
silencing agent l'agent du silence en
grippe par exemple il est tombé
oui oui c'est tout à fait naturel il me
semble pourquoi pas oui à c'est tout à
fait naturel qu'ils le fassent mais il
le fait dans une orbite qui est bonne
pour moi est bonne pour lui ce tout à
fait pur c'est tout à fait ça et ça lui
maintiennent dans un certain équilibre
aussi et moi ça va j'ai l'impression que
composant il est reçu un peu comme un
saint oui cela n'est ce pas la chose la
civilisation indienne est très là dessus
est un peu différente des autres que les
gens qui sont un peu fous sont touchés
par dieu est alors d'être touché par
dieu savourant indemne
n'est ce pas on vous a mais et c'est là
je crois que j'ai appris une grande
chose c'est que nos cultures doivent
survivre en admettant les faibles elle
est handicapée comme faisant partie de
nous mêmes
tout à coup j'ai compris cette leçon et
ça m'a ouvert énormément de choses que
même comme médecin je n'avais pas
compris mais pourtant c'est dur de vous
entendre dire parfois par lui que c'est
un peu de votre faute puisque c'est vous
qui l'avez fait venir en europe
c'est vrai c'est le destin on essaie de
faire le bien et ça tourne mal on fait
du mal et ça devient du bien je ne
comprends pas ça mais c'est calme mais
c'est le destin
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas dans
nos mains et voilà s'il n'était pas venu
en europe s'il n'avait pas été plein de
succès à envoyer engageant à envoyer en
libye et peut-être qu'il ne serait pas
devenu pas là parce que quand on est
rentré à oz
avec lui on a dit aux bains il y a des
centaines de méningite tuberculeuse
chaque semaine aux aides
on aurait tout de suite d'un diagnostic
et ça et c'est parce qu'il était dans un
très bon hôpital européen où on n'en
avait pas vu depuis 20 ans 30 ans on
n'avait pas vu un cas qu' il ya eu un
délai